things get really intense i don't have
time to go home and shower and change so
i just sleep here
this is not recommended for anyone i
just did it because
if i didn't do it then tesla good chance
has it would die
sleek is really great because because if
i find if i don't get enough sleep then
i'm i'm quite grumpy
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level of
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn some of
elon musk's best productivity
secrets enjoy
okay let's kick it off with secret
number one work super hard
this is widely regarded as one of the
most robotics driven auto assembly lines
on the planet elon part of the thing i
heard about the model 3 is that there's
too many robots that made it i
agree you do you think so too that maybe
you need more people in here working we
do
in some cases the robots actually slowed
the production yes they did
we had this crazy complex uh network of
conveyor belts and it was not working
so we got rid of that whole thing this
is cool elon
yeah realizing it needed an overhaul
musk personally took over the model 3
production line at the beginning of
april
rating for really extreme levels of
precision
more than any other vehicle in the world
he says he has resorted to pulling
all-nighters at the plant when things
get really intense i don't have time to
go home and shower and change so i just
sleep here i want to see
where is that oh yeah
i mean it's pretty boring overall really
um it's actually cold in here too
yeah i like it cool so you have a you
like it cold i sleep on the couch over
there
so you're just laying here on the couch
yeah last time this year i actually
slept
literally on the floor because the couch
was too narrow yeah i was gonna say
and elon i have to say it's not even a
comfortable couch either no it's
terrible
this is not a good catch musk feels like
all the overtime is paying off
and now he says the model 3 line is back
on track
and we're able to un unlock some of the
critical things that are holding us back
from reaching 2000 cars a week but since
then we've continued to do 2000 cars a
week
do you think that this is sustainable
this pace
is sustainable yeah you need to work if
depending on how
well you want to do and particularly if
you're starting a company you need to
work super hard
so what what does super hard mean um
well
when my brother and i were starting our
first company
instead of getting an apartment we just
rented a small office
and we slept on the couch uh and we
we showered at the the ymca and uh we're
we're so hot up we had just one computer
so the
the website was up during the day and i
was coding at night
seven days a week all the time um and i
i
sort of briefly had a girlfriend in that
period and in order to
be with me she had to sleep in the
office so
i work hard like
in it i mean every waking hour that's
that's the
the thing i would i would say if if you
particularly if you're starting a
company
um and i mean if you do simple math say
like okay if somebody else is working
50 hours and you're working 100 you'll
get twice as done
as much done in the course of a year as
the other company
secret number two get enough sleep
you're running
you're ceo of two companies you're
chairman of
talk about time management how on earth
do you do this
well do you get any sleep uh yeah
sometimes not enough sleep is really
great
uh because because if i find if i don't
get enough sleep then i'm i'm quite
grumpy
um i mean obviously i think most people
are that way
and and also like i try to sort of
figure out what's the
right amount of sleep because like i
found i could have
i could drop below a certain threshold
of sleep and although i'd be awake more
hours and i could sustain it
i would get less done because um
my mental acuity would be affected
so i found generally the right number
for me is around six to six and a half
hours
on average per night secret number three
be willing to make sacrifices
i mean tesla really faced the severe
threat threat of death
due to the model 3 production ramp
essentially
the company was bleeding money like
crazy and and just
if if we didn't solve these problems in
a very short period of time uh we would
die
uh and it was extremely difficult to
solve them how close to death did you
come
we are within single-digit weeks
22 hours a day or like what how many
hours working yeah seven days a week
sleeping in the factory uh i worked
everywhere from i worked in the
paint shop general assembly body shop
you ever worry about yourself
imploding like it's just too much
absolutely no one should
put this many hours into work
this is not good people should not work
this hard i'm not
they should not do this this is very
painful
painful in what sense it's because my
ears my brain
and my heart so it's this is not
recommended for anyone
i just did it because if i didn't do it
then tesla
your chat says it would die also if you
want to have more confidence self-love
self-belief check out my 254 series
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to build a habit
so i've designed a special free program
to help you get it
where i will send you an unlisted video
to your email for the next 254 days to
shift
your self belief forward the link to
sign up for free
is in the description below there are
just times when
something is important enough that you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear before we
were able to get the roadster out
then they'd say well you couldn't
possibly make that car work
secret number four use management by
rhyming
actual total mass of a steel
a reusable steel spacecraft is less than
that of the most advanced carbon fiber
vehicle you could possibly imagine yeah
wow this happened by accident by the way
this may sound like some
great insight but it actually happened
because we were moving too slowly on
composite
um and i was like we cannot move this
slowly or we'll go bankrupt
so just do this with steel
so yeah i mean the design has to be
focused on problem solving otherwise
you're going to spend too much time
trying to figure
you don't start with a yeah yeah i'm
like
sort of taken to management management
by rhyming if the schedule is
your schedule is long your design is
wrong right
this is a very true good point yes
secret number five have a great team you
need a team
around you to deliver a lot of idea how
do you choose your team
based on what
well um i suppose honestly that
it tends to be gut feel more than
anything else so when
i interview somebody my interview
question is always the same
it's just i said tell me the story of
your life
and and the decisions that you made
along the way and why you made them
and then um
if and and also tell me about some of
the most difficult problems you worked
on
and how you solved them and um
that that that question i think is very
important because
the people that really solve the problem
they know
exactly how they solved it they know the
little details
and the people that pretended to solve
the problem they can maybe go one level
and then they get stuck and secret
number six the last one before a very
special bonus clip
is integrate having a sort of
having a smartphone is incredibly
helpful because that means you can do
email
during interstitial periods like you're
in a car you're walking in the bathroom
everywhere
you can do email practically when you're
awake um
and uh and so that's really helpful to
have
email for spacex and tesla integrated on
my phone
um and then uh
and then just you have to apply a lot of
hours to actual working
actually working so the way i generally
do it is i'll be
working at spacex on monday and then
monday night flight to the bay area
spent tuesday and state in the bay area
then at tesla and then fly back on
wednesday night
spend thursday and friday at spacex
um in in the last several months then i
would fly back here on a saturday
and either spend saturday and sunday at
tesla
uh or spend saturday at tesla and sunday
at spacex
and where and where did the boys fit in
you have five sons
um yeah do they tag along with dad on
some of these
i do drag them along a lot of things
actually um they're remarkably
unimpressed
by yeah
i wish they were sort of more interested
but i mean they're only the twins
are eight and the triplets are six so
maybe they'll get more
more interested later but do you see one
day grooming one of them or
several of them to take over your
companies
well i i mean i think if if they're
inclined to
i mean if they're really interested in
working at tesla or spacex then i
you know help them do that um i'm not
sure i'd want to
necessarily try to insert them into the
ceo role at some point you know
it's kind of like if if uh if the rest
of the team and the
board kind of felt that they were the
right person then that would be
that would be fine but uh i wouldn't
want
people to feel like i kind of you know
installed
you know like my kid there um i don't
think that would be good for either
the companies or the kid really now i've
got a special bonus clip that i think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know what was your single biggest
takeaway from
this video and what is your plan of
action for the next week
the sign says that when you just watch a
video you get motivated you get inspired
you have a 35 chance of actually doing
something following through
that believe nation is not enough 35
percent
is not enough we got to do something but
when you get inspired by watching a
video like this
and then you create a plan of action
your chances of following through jump
to 91 and when you commit publicly
like putting your comment down below
with your plan it jumps in 95
that's what i want for you i want you to
take action your dreams are too
important
your life matters your mission has to
happen
so question of the day your biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week put it down in the comments below
and i'm going to celebrate alongside
with you i remember when you first told
me
that you were thinking about tunnels
when did i first tell you about that
years ago okay it's like a long time ago
like i thought you were joking
yeah it was i was joking but
um it's not because of some epiphany
that i had one day
um driving down the 405.
that's how it gets translated somehow i
was talking about tunnels for years and
years
um for probably five years or four years
at least
whenever i'd give a talk and people
would ask me about what opportunities
you do you see in the world i'd say
tunnels can someone please build tunnels
so after four or five years of begging
people to build tunnels
and still no tunnels i was like okay
i want to build a tunnel
it's like maybe they're missing
something here um
so um yes i was like basically talking
people's ears or tunnels for for several
years
and then said well let's find out what
it takes to build a tunnel
and um yeah so i started doing a tunnel
i wanted to start the tunnel from
where i could see it from my office at
spacex so i said well let's just
carve off a part of the parking lot
across the road so i can see if it's
if anything's happening or not
um and then we named our first boring
machine uh
godot because i kept waiting for it it
never came
um finally it did
and we got it going and now we're making
good progress
[Music]
if you want to know how elon musk fixed
tesla's problems check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there you like it cole
i sleep on the couch right there
so you're just laying here yeah the
couch yeah last time this year i
actually slept literally on the floor
because the couch was too narrow
so when i interview somebody